افادت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه باستشهاد
الشاب جبريل اللدعه البالغ من العمر 17
عاما برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واصابه
سته اخرين خلال اقتحام الاحتلال لمخيم
عقبه جبر في اريحا صباح اليوم وكانت قوات
الاحتلال قد شنت صباح اليوم حمله مداهمات
في مناطق متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه تخللها
تفتيش عدد من المنازل
ومواجهات بين الشبان الفلسطينيين والجيش
الاسرائيلي
قد نددت وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه باشد
العبارات بالاقتحام الدموي والهمجي الذي
ارتكبته قوات الاحتلال صباح اليوم في مخيم
عقبه جبر في اريحا شرق ضفه الغربيه وفي
تغريده على حسابها في موقع تويتر دنت
الوزاره جرائم الاحتلال المتواصله في
اريحا معتبره انها نتيجه لافلاته المستمر
من العقاب
انضم الينا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد الحصيله النهائيه ربما
والتي استقر عليها الوضع بخصوص هذا
الاقتحام في اريحا وما جرى بعده
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت قد اقتحمت
مدينه اريحا وتحديدا مخيم عقبه جبر في
الشمالي المدينه في جنوبي المدينه وقامت
بمحاصره بيت هناك بذريعه انها تبحث عن
منصفهم بالمطلوبين لكنها اطلقت النيران
بكثافه فقتلت الفتى جبريل اللدعه 17 عاما
واصابت سته اخرين بجراح مستشفى اريحا
افادها بان ثلاثه منهم تم تحويلهم الى
المستشفيات في رام الله نظرا لخطوره
حالتهم هذا الاقتحام لقوات الاحتلال الذي
يصفه الفلسطينيون بالاعتداء المتواصل
تحديدا على منطقه اريحا خلال الاسابيع
الثلاثه الاخيره بعد عمليه الفلسطينيه
التي استهدفت سياره للمستوطنين وقتلت
ثلاثه منهم في منطقه الحمراء في الاغوار
الشماليه وقوات الاحتلال تركز بشكل متواصل
على منطقه اريحا لانها لم تضبط حتى الان
الذين نفذوا ذاك الهجوم هذا اقتحام ياتي
في اطار سلسله من الاقتحامات الاخرى التي
استهدفت عددا من البلدات الفلسطينيه بينها
قريوت وطمون في منطقه نابلس ومخيم نور شمس
في منطقه طولكرم وبتونيا غربيه رام الله
وكذلك مدينه الخليل لكن ايضا منطقه وبلدتي
بيت جالا تحديدا غربيه مدينه بيت لحم حيث
افاد مستشفى بيت جالا بان قوات الاحتلال
التي توغلت في داخل هذه البلده صباح اليوم
كانت قد اطلقت الاعيره الناريه والمطاطيه
وقنابل الغاز التي روعت النزلاء
والمرضى في المستشفى
وتسببت باختناقات داخله لكن الابرز انها
ان وزاره الصحه وكذلك المستشفى افاد بان
مواطنا قد اصيب بجراح خطيره جدا في صدره
جراء اصابته برصاص الدمدم المتفجر الذي
اطلقه جنود الاحتلال عليه العمليه هذا
الاجراء الاسرائيلي او هذه العم السيده
متواصله تاتي كما يقول جيش الاحتلال في
اطار ما تسميها عمليه كاسر الامواج
المتواصله منذ نحو عام والتي استهدفت في
الماضي وتركزت بشكل خاص على مناطق جنين
ونابلس لكنها توسعت لتشمل ايضا منطقه
اريحا يضاف الى هذا كله بان الفلسطينيون
وعلى كافه المستويات سواء الرسميه او
الشعبيه يرون بانهم عرضه لاعتداءات
اسرائيليه متواصله وتصعيد متواصل فمنذ
بدايه هذا العام ومع سقوط الشهيد الجديد
جبريل اللدعه في اريحا يكون قد ارتفع عدد
الفلسطينيين الذين استشهدوا بنيران
الاحتلال الى 104 شهداء وهناك عدد كبير
يزيد على 2000 معتقل في كافه المناطق منذ
بدايه هذا العام جراء المداهمات
والاعتقالات التي تقوم بها قوات الاحتلال
والتي عززت وتنشر الكثير من
حواجزها في انحاء مختلفه من الضفه الغربيه
بينما هناك حاله من الفلتان يقوم بها
المستوطنين وايضا ويشكلون من خلالها خطوره
متواصله على المواطنين وحياتهم وكانت قد
ظهرت بشكل جلي في منطقه نابلس تحديدا
وبلده حواره خلال الفتره السابقه ولد
العمري مدير مكتبنا من رام الله شكرا
جزيلا لك